hey what's up this is John Maloney with
Ramsey Network we are back with Pastor
John Hazen and talk him up what's going
on in my neighborhood what's going on in
your neighborhood what's going on in our
hearts and I want to model with
submission looks like I don't a model
what listening and learning looks like
and shutting our mouths so in the last
last time in the last video we talked
about model neighborhood you gave me a
history lesson on my neighbor that
didn't know all right these sidewalks it
my kids run on that were paved by the
blood sweat and tears of other folks and
we often live in that what's tomorrow
gonna look like what's tomorrow gonna
look like and I don't pay attention to
the sidewalks that I'm walking on that
were laid by other people and you and I
talked before we even started recording
that I got a passion for the secondary
traumatic stress helpers who help other
people and the people people who end up
in helping rolls usually through the
course of their life I've either been
forced into a helper role or they have
found success and a helper all their
natural leaders they're people people go
to all right you've got a history in the
military you got a history of working
with young people and so naturally over
the course of how many years you have
formed yourself or have let others
speaking to you and you've become now a
leader in our community far beyond just
one church right I'm interested in with
all due respect not Pastor John
Faison sure I'm interested in this guy
John that works in my neighborhood how
are you I'm exhausted I'm exhausted I'm
tired yeah and that's that's a hard
place to be on the front end of a trauma
what I mean it's the hard place to build
a Friday but man it is it is a picture
of a lot of a lot of folks who look like
me yeah yeah you're deflecting again how
are you Joe is gone doing so heavy oh no
no I know I know I know I'm exhausted
I'm tired
um yeah
we get the accumulative the cumulative
effect of trauma but also trauma now has
proximity to terrorize us every day
because of social media and access to
technology and everywhere you go it's
it's constantly there and I know the
where dis of education is necessary but
uh yeah the we often tell people you can
sit in it but don't bathe in it yeah
right yeah you got you got it you gotta
find something something to do with it
mmm and and that's that's that's what
I've been trying to spend the last
probably last four or five days doing
okay
working through processing and putting
the trauma somewhere not letting it sit
in in your soul were you putting it man
there's a lot of guys put it on their
wives mmm they put on their kids they
put it out on these stupid boxes right
well listen self-care self-care is is my
wife's a therapist so that helps with
quite a bit of this stuff so working out
that there's a there's a there's a
physical heaviness that sits on you and
we deal with trauma you got to get that
stuff out yep
sweating you know exercise for that
helps works for me having a safe space a
group of friends of accountability folks
but also just folks where I could just
say what I need to say man and get get
it out into into space that makes you
rare air for a pastor
there's myths themself to a group of
people that hold you accountable gotta
have it gotta have it everybody else
people freeze you somebody you don't got
to give names but that their past how
did it their past of salt so so when I
cover those spaces I don't have to
explain they get it already but I walk
into that space it's it's an under
what's what's understood don't have to
be explained so there's a space that
we've we've created when I got to
Nashville man I pray to God
cuz I'm not from here mmm I pray I
prayed to God God send me some friends I
need I need I need some I need some real
authentic relationships I can't do I
don't I don't do full connection
don't know I don't do a lot of
superficial stuff I need a space that's
safe I need a space where I can be John
and and without apology without defense
without being judged and without ending
up on Facebook and it's gonna see it yes
yeah yes every leader needs that
everybody person needs that everybody
needs it man and God answered the
prayers okay so I got I got two brothers
man that I just thought of my guys so a
gift to me is to know the process one of
things that's come on the pandemic is
I'm lonely I moved to Nashville a couple
years ago I sit a couple of grown men at
my kitchen table and said I'm asking you
to be my friend
one of them burst into tears because
they'd never been asked that question as
a grown up and the other one looked at
me if I he looked at me pretty weird
yeah what is the process you went
through to identify those folks man I
did you get off phone people reach out
to you I wish I had a process man I wish
I could tell you what the process was it
was really God answered the prayer
because I was too busy I didn't have
time to go hunt for friends and being a
new pastor in a new city you don't know
who you can trust anyway that's exactly
right
brand-new an old pastor nosotras late I
don't you don't can't trust everybody
they're just pictures you get with
everybody so I prayed I asked God to
send them to me to show them to me and
God did that and I you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't there wasn't this you know
Mount Sinai moment right with a burning
bush it this is my first this guy Tom
walks out and says hello it's not it's
not that but God just kind of showed I
remember the first time that I connected
with my best friend in Nashville maybe
we just went to lunch we've been trying
to catch each other and he's a pastor
I'm a pastor we would try to catch each
other I mean we went to lunch man and I
think we'd schedule lunch one hour man
we were in left for four hours we're at
that table for four hours just talking
just downloading just share it just
connect and that was that that birthed
it that started it because it was easy
to he was easy to talk to
he understood kind of what it means to
me in our cultural world he passes a
large Church in this view and we had a
chance to just connect man and and we
both cancelled all the rest of our
meetings for the rest of the day and
just hung out and talked did you leave
that it was 30 pounds lighter listen man
at least 40 release 15 man it was it was
a game-changing moment for me because
God had given me an adult friend okay
right as as kids friendship comes a
little easier but as a judge man it's
it's tough to develop friendships and
God gave me that gift and and got and
God knows he had to send it to me cuz I
don't know how I would I would have
pursued it so my confession here is I've
been in Nashville for two years now a
little more than two years I've tried
but I have not prayed for friends and
that will start today wherever I listen
ass ass for community can you show fight
a knock at the door sure be careful all
right I'm calling your bluff Pastor John
on your mother ever see so walk me
through um being a husband and being a
dad in this when your neighborhoods on
fire yeah cuz you got to take care of
your people like your your job yeah and
I know being a pastor's are calling up
but it's your job you take care of
people you got to take care of every
white friend you have that is calling
you for I'm sorry you've got a book for
me what can I do
I told one of my buddies I was like you
just started giving them your VIN mo and
say hey I just need cash and no I said
give me money but so you got that right
you've got all these other people
dropping their bricks in your backpack
right now there but your priority is
your wife and your kids yes and you got
hold your kids man 21 19 and 60 see
you've got 21 19 and 16 year olds so now
you got little pieces of your heart
driving through these neighborhoods
little blue you got little pieces of
your heart
wondering are they gonna be able to go
to a grocery store and come back home
yeah yeah your wife trying to figure out
be a therapist in a quarantine yeah
walk me through that man it's uh it's
it's but it's been a glorious hard time
you gotta unpack that I've got two kids
I've got two kids who are college okay
until the middle of a pandemic they came
back home and went online for the rest
of the semester they want summer jobs
I'm not sure if we're gonna let them
have summer jobs okay because of the
core tech and you get exposed to to
stuff too virus and you can bring it
back home and you know my wife has is
one of those persons with kind of a
compromised immune system so you've got
to you got to be careful how you do it
anything less why I got my mask you know
you know hand sanitizer I'm trying to
hospitality right trying to make room
and make space for folks to stay safe
and stay safe and healthy got a son who
just turned 16 he's giving your license
and man I'm not in a hurry to give it to
no my oldest son turned 21 on Tuesday
this week but Saturday we were at a
protest downtown and that's doing it
together him aboard my daughter is 19
and feels everything yeah right so it's
about making space for them to be able
to vent and talk but also trying to
provide tools and tips for them to
process trauma deal with that be young
adults but also what do you do with it
how do you channel it into something
that that's that's effective something
that's healthy yeah but they want to
make a difference that's that's that
generation Millennials Z's and younger
they want to make an impact man they you
know it don't don't don't just tell me
what's wrong
show me how I can help and so trying to
channel that energy and that that
tension and that trauma in an area that
that that's productive and efficient how
is their outlook impacted you in a
positive way
oh man I'm just mad I'm I'm I am so
proud of them
I'm expand listen I'm so proud of them
and excited that they are woke
okay that they see what's happening and
they don't run from they they diagnose
it they recognize it and a lot of that
comes from the conversations we've had
since they were kids we've never shied
away and pulled them away from the
challenges that happening in the world
and and just really tried to raise them
to see that your gifts are designed to
meet a great need in the world and so
you can't be in purpose if you don't
explore needs if you are sheltered
completely from brokenness
you'll never find purpose in this world
you have to see brokenness to see where
your gifts meet that brokenness and if
you don't find purpose you don't find
wholeness you don't find life you don't
have life you don't relations you don't
have enough I don't have it so watching
them grow and develop and see this is
where I can make a difference this is
where I can make it impact dad how do I
do this and day it out away man it makes
me super proud and I know that's from
conversations that we that started when
they were kids yeah man I grew up in a
place called Southampton County okay
Virginia okay it's on the border of
North Carolina it is as rural and his
country as they come
okay for better or for worse right right
for all of it right now when I came to
Nashville I discovered I was in the
south
okay but I thought in Virginia I was in
the south because Virginia is the seat
of the Confederacy okay it but when I
got to naturally like now you from the
East Coast from but but but I had I had
southern experiences as a kid yeah I
grew up on a street called Cross Keys
Road Cross Keys Road is best known for
1831 okay 1831 there was a gentleman
named nat turner yep was a slave who led
a slave insurrection a revolt 1831 that
slave insurrection started on the street
a global so that's that's that that's
that's the the air I breathed as a kid
and my parents both sides of that air
right we're the end of it and my parents
were intentional about making sure that
not only did we know that history we
were proud of it okay now the county I
grew up in is not proud of that history
correct because there is a goodness
there's a legacy of terror and
trauma that resulted before that and
even after that man to this to this day
there is a hanging tree road in that
Kelly that's the name of street to this
day there is a black head signpost road
in that county it sound it it is exactly
what it sounds like
post nat turner after the revolt a I'm
frozen you know what to say after the
revolt slavery was already terrorism
right on black black bodies they they
turned it up because they was so afraid
of another rebellion that rebellion
killed 61 people they were so afraid of
that rebellion they took Nat Turner
before they hanged him they skinned him
alive in the courthouse in South Hampton
County
somewhere there is his sort that he
carried but there's also a belt and a
lampshade made from his skin yeah let's
get him alive din they hang right and so
there was his fear of what would happen
if the revolt occurred every vote like
that occurred again and so they begin to
Institute even more draconian
terroristic practices slavery got worse
if that's possible
gotcha so one of the things he would do
is if there was a slave that was away
from plantation or a slave that was
alone yeah they capture him cut his head
off
mmm now put a post in front of the
plantation and sit his head on the post
kind of Lord of the Flies kind of moment
yeah and that would become your
psychological reminder that you don't
want to do this again my aunt lives on
that road black hair samples rule now
there are two versions of this right in
2020 that sounds terrible
who would want that as their address oh
my god my community says that's the name
we wanted the edges because if you
change the name you'll forget the
history of history
mr. reclamation you're you'll erase it
and act like it didn't happen and
generations that go that come after
subsequent generations will never know
story because it's not taught in public
schools it's not taught in I've heard a
lot about in that Turner and I never
heard that this it's not taught it's not
taught our community keeps it alive
because the story needs to be told right
historians will tell you NAT Turner's
insurrection was one of the pivotal
moments that ultimately led to civil
right and I've heard that part of it
absolutely I haven't heard the other
part mm-hmm
so what happened in your heart you grew
up in that community I don't know if
about trauma that's like being born in a
fireplace
and you had parents who cared about you
and said we're gonna look you know we're
gonna teach you about the road you've
grown up on and then neighborhood you're
growing up on both sides yes what
happened in your heart that kept you
from growing up and say I'm gonna burn
everything to the ground and then when
you had your three kids and you knew the
struggles which you grew up in you moved
here when o8 2012 in 2012 so eight years
ago eight years ago your 21 year old as
a kid uh-huh your 16 year old it was hey
I got ten year old yeah what happened in
your heart that said I'm going to use
I'm gonna model what this is gonna look
like I'm gonna use teaching I'm use
education I'm gonna use I'm gonna take
them with me let them see with their own
eyes but we're also gonna talk about
channeling I I don't I'm confident
huh I'm confident that I would not have
the heart to train my kids in that way I
think my bent would be to Train warriors
not thinkers and Saints what happened in
your heart
to shift that well I would say maybe a
bit instead what happened you heart huh
how was a heart like that grow um that's
not very fertile soil out it's more
fertile than you think okay tell me I
had parents it's a lot of back
I had a mazing mom and dad okay I have
an amazing mom at their country it's
Laurie yeah
people always understand urban problems
and challenges in the urban setting what
people realize is the same challenge as
a family rule setting right you got
rural poverty just like you have urban
park and food deserts inhospitable
deserts in their 2020 in my County there
are folks who have outhouses hmm they
weren't running water 2020 all right no
computer access for their children hmm
no so what paper are you writing all
right now how do you how do you navigate
this world so solos chain challenges so
my parents both had graduate degrees in
our county that put us in a very very
privileged space okay because that's not
everybody's story okay my parents from
the time I got here exposed us and told
us how blessed we were and how that is a
responsibility now to provide for others
what you don't have what they don't have
for themselves and so that became the
ethos okay so every Christmas man before
we opened a gift we went around blessing
kids who didn't have anything hmm
my parents retired and built what's
called a borgen's neighborhood outreach
center it's a community center in the
woods okay all right good yeah it's a
rural community center that addresses
the lack of running water that addresses
the lack computer access that addresses
the digital divide for seniors and
provides them computer literacy they
they bought a house built it next door
to them and turn it into a community sir
so that's that's that's what I saw all
my life's real fertile soil that's what
I saw my life even in the midst of the
challenge isn't see that we see my
father
is on the Board of Supervisors which is
like the Metro Council yeah here we're
for City it's on the Board of
Supervisors is for the county and he
advocates and fights and engages my mom
is a English teacher and taught for
years but is also a preacher and
pastored my home church for about three
years that's that's where I come from
okay
so it was not it was natural for me to
understand that you take what you have
you expose you educate you give you
provide experiences but always
understand that the blessings you have a
burdens for somebody else that the
blessings you enjoy somebody doesn't
have those and you have a responsibility
not not not not a not an opportunity you
have a responsibility to make sure that
those who don't have access to what you
have get a chance to experience as best
as you can provide you are not blessed
to simply enjoy blessings you are
blessed to be a blessing and that's the
ethos that I was raised on my brothers
and sisters I'm 105 and and and that's
what we attempt my wife and I to how we
attempt to raise our children and and I
think that you you can't shelter them
from the realities of life here shelter
them from the culture they're living in
if you don't teach them about the world
the world will teach them about the
world that's right but they may not
survive the world's education they'll
survive yours so I think you got to be
honest you got to be genuine you got you
you got to expose them to the realities
so they walk into it eyes wide open but
they also realize man there's something
in me that's designed for this moment
and so that that's how we attempt to
raise IQ I'll cut it off here we're
gonna go back cow man this is the only
show where I'm not even gonna say
anything I'm on styling anything
straight how do you know what to say so
this dr. John Doe Loney we were checking
out of here
we'll be back talk to you soon I don't
say